hi there steve kaufman here um
i often get asked to provide uh
subtitles or a transcript for the videos
that i do in other languages i simply
don't have time to do this
uh you know it's it's basically all i'm
able to do is to do some of these videos
every now and again and
i'm just not going to provide
um
transcripts but people are welcome to do
so if they want to do so what i am going
to do though is i'm going to more or
less cover the same ground here in
english that i covered
in my two most recent videos in chinese
and japanese
so that might help you
uh
with the japanese when i mentioned first
of all that we are going to have another
hangout
and i'm actually planning to have it on
thursday
uh
at 4 pm pacific standard time which is
midnight greenwich mean time or
coordinated whatever it's called utc or
something time in other words
uh you know one hour to the
east of europe i guess
um
so if you want to join me and we don't
know what language we're going to be
speaking probably english but if people
want to come in japanese or in other
languages that's fine
that time slot does work for asia so
hopefully we'll have some participants
from japan or china or korea
so if you can make it please come to the
link page at google plus
or let me know here at my youtube
channel so it was the first point i
mentioned and the second point is i
wanted to cover this issue of input
based learning it goes
by different names in japan it's called
tadoku tacho in other words listen a lot
or read a lot listen a lot and basically
that's what it amounts to it amounts to
spending most of your time listening and
reading and working on your vocabulary
and becoming familiar with the language
rather than on outbook output activities
or grammar-focused activities that
doesn't mean that there is no output or
that people don't look at grammar but it
just means that the bulk of the time is
spent on listening and reading and
building up
vocabulary and why do i think this is a
better way to learn languages i have
five reasons first of all because it
works it works very well some of the
best polyglots on the internet or the
famous cattle lomb
if you study their methods you'll see
that it generally involves a lot of
reading 100 years or so 150 years ago
and of course today with the
availability of new technology listening
so and in my own case it's worked for me
and my most recent experience was czech
where for the first eight months i only
listened and read and then gradually
started speaking and stepped up speaking
uh just prior to going to prague and i
arrived in prague and i could understand
everything and my speaking uh which was
already at a call at an intermediate you
know low intermediate level i think i
stepped up to maybe a
middle intermediate level and of course
you have to continue speaking but i was
able to do all that because i had a
sound basis in the language and that
sound basis comes from a lot of
listening reading so
it's effective number one number two
it's easy you can do it anywhere you can
do it listening in your car washing the
dishes as i do or exercising and you
just have it with you you're waiting
somewhere you do it so it's very easy
similarly with reading particularly now
i didn't mention it in chinese or
japanese but we have our ipad app so if
you're doing it
uh at link or somewhere else you can
have
reading on your ipad you can print stuff
and read it you can borrow stuff from
the library you can do it it's so
flexible you don't have to go to a
classroom half an hour to get there sit
in the class half an hour to come back
uh
also in terms of effectiveness uh i just
wanted to mention too like if you're
listening or reading you're you're a
hundred percent with the language in a
classroom half the time you're having to
listen to other students who may not use
the language as well as you do
and so it's to my mind much less
effective than time you spend with the
language the third thing about input
based learning is you're not making
mistakes a lot of people are afraid to
make mistakes if you're forced to speak
you'll make mistakes
uh
you're listening you can't make a
mistake when you're listening you might
misunderstand something you might not it
might be a little fuzzy at times you may
have the wrong interpretation there's
words you don't understand none of that
matters that's part of the process
that's part of the process
and things that are unclear and fuzzy at
an early stage will eventually start to
become clearer so you're not really
making mistakes but you're in that stage
of your learning where the brain is
gradually becoming more and more
familiar with the language you're
learning more and more words and of
course things are going to be unclear to
you
so that's an advantage another advantage
of listening and reading is that you can
do things that are interesting because
you can choose what you want to listen
to and read
obviously the first month or so you're
stuck with beginner material which is
often not very interesting but i
certainly encourage people to move
beyond the beginner material as soon as
possible to get into things of interest
because i certainly find that if i find
something of interest i will work even
if there's a lot of unknown words i'll
work hard with that text because it's of
interest to me
so you can be doing stuff that's of
interest and in the case of my tech
learning
my russian before that i was able to
learn so much about czech history the
history of central europe uh political
situation in czech
czech
republic
so when i get to prague i have all this
wonderful background so you're doing
stuff that's interesting you're learning
other things
besides just the language itself which
is more interesting than sitting in a
classroom again because they're
necessarily you're dealing with learner
material that's been devised by someone
to make sure it includes all of this
vocabulary and this grammar structure
and stuff which which often makes it
very uninteresting
and finally learning uh via an input
based approach
is cheaper because you can you don't
have to spend anything you can go to the
library you know you can find stuff on
the internet if you want to uh there are
services like link or you can buy
yourself an assy mail or you can buy
yourself a pimsleur whatever
but it's still a lot less expensive than
going to class
so now it may be that someone else is
paying for the class but that doesn't
change the fact that the class is
expensive inherently because you have a
trained professional there in front of
uh students someone's got to pay for him
i'm not i'm not saying you shouldn't go
to class
but
even if you do the main emphasis in my
opinion should be on input based
learning now input based learning has
a drawback
and that is that for it to be effective
you have to be motivated you have to be
disciplined you have to be a
self-starter
uh you have to be curious about things
you have to go out and find content of
interest
you have to have the confidence that you
can succeed and this is often the
problem with with inexperienced lions
learners who have never really become
fluent in another language they can't
visualize themselves as fluent so
they're kind of half defeated before
they start they think they'll never get
there and if you think that then
probably you won't so you have to be a
positive confident
motivated
independent learner
however
if you go to a class and you aren't a
confident motivated independent learner
you won't either you won't learn either
and
i i mentioned the chinese
video that i did that they did a study
of chinese immigrants to canada and
found that in seven years they followed
about 3 000 immigrants who were taking
esl
here at these government-sponsored
schools and there was essentially no
improvement statistically no improvement
uh those that spoke well when they
arrived spoke well continue to speak
well and those that didn't speak when
they arrived still couldn't speak very
well so
that's just to say that very often the
classroom environment if the learner is
not motivated in other words doesn't
have all the qualities that you require
to be an independent learner and to take
advantage of listening and reading and
input based learning if you don't have
those qualities you won't be successful
in the classroom either so the classroom
can provide a lot of benefits social
benefits and feedback and so forth but
even if you're in a classroom
make sure that your main emphasis is on
listening and reading and building up
your vocabulary and there you have it
i'm sure that i'll get a lot of flack
back for this one but i really strongly
believe it it's it's the thing that
people don't understand you don't have
to speak from day one you don't have to
do drills you have to listen and read a
lot thank you for listening